entrer dans l'atelier de jean paul
riopelle c'est faire un voyage dans le
temps pour renouer avec un artiste qui a
marqué l'histoire de l'art issu du
mouvement des automatistes des
signataires du refus global ses oeuvres
sont reconnus et vendus partout dans le
monde
en plus d'une de ces voitures anciennes
et de sa collection de mouches à pêche
on retrouve ces pinceau et de la
peinture abandonné en pleine création
évidemment on va pour être serré ça du
lieu sa fille notre guide est le fils du
guide vachon la dernière épouse de
riopelle ça ressemble presque à un musée
en fait ouais ben c'est pas mal ça c'est
à dire que le lieu est et reste un peu
figé dans le temps
moi j'ai pas vu jean-paul travail ici
parce que à l'époque où moi j'ai connu à
partir de l'âge de 6 ans il travaillait
à l'étagé inférieur
mais par contre ici c'est new york de
fait beaucoup de peinture dans la fin
des années soixante dix l'atelier
construit en 1974 a été dessiné par ea
opel lui-même qu on arrive ici on pense
presque c'est une grange tout le
bâtiment à l'extérieur est d'ailleurs
recouvert de vieux bois de grange
également qui a été récupéré ici il
n'entre pas qui veut dans l'atelier mais
samedi prochain il accueillera
exceptionnellement un événement bénéfice
au profit de clavecin en concert le lieu
d'abord pour moi ça on aurait dit une
chapelle et souvent les récital de
clavecin ou les récitals de musique de
chambre baroque
comment on fait on les fait
dans des chapelles alors s'allier pour
moi ça veut dire déjà eu lieu cet
événement sera l'occasion de découvrir
des oeuvres inédites
c'est une oeuvre qui a été déménagé de
la france mais c'est là peut-être la
seule sculpture de riopelle ou notamment
on peut on peut retrouver d'aidé il
aurait touché avec la peinture
quel sera l'avenir de l'atelier de
riopelle l'objectif est d'en perpétuer
la mémoire ici tanya lapointe radio
canada cette marguerite du lac masson